turning now to a highly anticipated
series by academy award winner barry
jenkins he's directed
some of the most powerful and
consequential films in recent years they
include best picture winner moonlight
and the critically acclaimed adaptation
of james baldwin's novel if beale street
could talk
his latest project the underground
railroad premieres tomorrow on amazon
prime
we met up with barry jenkins in la to
discuss the series
which has been four years in the making
he said it was the hardest undertaking
he's ever attempted in his creative life
[Music]
barry jenkins had long wanted to direct
a story about slavery
in america i knew at some point i was
going to have to use
my art my voice to speak to
my ancestors as much as you wanted to
film this story you were also in some
ways afraid of it
i was it's a it's very tricky
delicate difficult subject matter the
underground railroad
based on colson whitehead's pulitzer
prize-winning novel
tells the story of cora randall a slave
in the antebellum south
who flees a georgia plantation there is
[Music]
the underground railroad isn't symbolic
it's real a network of tracks beneath
the southern soil
that leads to freedom that's just how
jenkins had imagined it
growing up and so when i first heard the
conceit of coulson's book
i thought oh this is it and for me it
was about chasing that childhood feeling
you felt it was important to tell this
story in an epic fashion
i did yeah i did remembering as a child
it wasn't superman it wasn't batman it
wasn't spider-man
it was the underground railroad to me
that was
larger than life the fantasy for me was
my ancestors built trains underground
and secret
harriet tubman was on the front of the
train with a shotgun
picking people off you know now we
didn't go that far
in the recreation of this show um but
that was the feeling and
that's epic with a capital e
played by south african actress tuso
imbedu
chases the promise of freedom through
five states
everybody keep telling me how special i
am
what good is a railroad if only special
folk can take it
yeah i made that one up like two days
before we shot it you made the scene up
that's not in the book yeah i was like
we
she needs to interrogate this world
right so this is what we came up with
you came all this way on the railroad
here and left behind all those peoples
as jenkins planned the filming of the 10
episode series
he found that few of the old slaves
quarters
remained in the south so you basically
built your own plantation
we built it i mean the whole thing we
planted sugar cane we planted cotton
we built all the cabins i had never
stood in a cotton field before
and standing in that cotton field was
heavy
hair and it was hard to not be
emotionally swept up in the fact that i
was walking through history
and some of that history is very
difficult to process do you get
emotional on the side
i did a couple times a couple times yeah
yeah i did you're smiling
no because it surprised me man you
actually brought a therapist to the set
i did i did did you ever need her not
that i knew
uh but there was a day where she came to
me and she pulled me aside and she said
hey
you need to come talk to me i say we
talking about i'm fine i got to be
strong for the crew
i'll never forget she said yes but who
is going to be strong
for you yeah if you keep holding all
this weight shooting the nearly 10-hour
series
took 116 days you were warned
going into this by some director friends
that this was an epic task i was and
it was steven soderbergh and carrie
fuganaga both told me
it was impossible and it was going to
kill me
and i was going to retire somewhere in
the middle of production but that i
would ultimately keep going
and all those things were true they were
yeah i retired at least five times
in the making of this show but jenkins
finally made it through
those 116 days of filming
then as editing began protests over the
death of george floyd
broke out and i thought
i wish i could go back and rewrite the
show and
make it speak to all these things that
are happening in the world right now
didn't have that luxury so we kept
editing and then of course i realized
oh it's all here because it's
always been here when the trailer for
the underground railroad was released
jenkins saw himself becoming a subject
on social media
and there was one thread of the
conversation that really bothered me it
was
we don't need images of slaves we need
positive imagery
and what i hear in that is inherently
any images
featuring my ancestors are inherently
negative yeah
and i just can't accept that what it
shows me is we actually need
more of these images so we can take back
their legacy
and recontextualize it the series is
about the darkness
of slavery but it's also a story of
survival
and triumph yes a story jenkins says
we've only just begun to tell you see
yourself as having a responsibility now
oh absolutely man especially being black
and this is this is the real real
i have to make it so undeniable
i have to be so good every damn day
because if this show doesn't work it
might mean
someone else how are they going to get
the funding for that if
my thing doesn't work yeah it's a brutal
way to go about making art
um but i was born black in america man
it's true
and all those sets that jenkins says
they built for for this series
he has left standing yeah he says
because he wants people to continue to
tell this story in as many ways as
as they can find it i say let the church
say amen to what he just said next
and uh listen i haven't seen it yet i
can't wait it's extremely powerful
that's what oprah said open oprah who is
very
very rarely watches tv said it's one of
the most powerful things he's ever seen
he's beautifully shot it's beautifully
active it's extremely powerful
i asked him because it was entirely shot
in georgia and i said given what's
happened in georgia with the voting
rights laws and the protests
how do you feel he said well this story
was based in georgia that's why we shot
it there
but he said today he said if i was
starting again he said i'd shoot it
somewhere else
can't wait thank you barry jenkins
though yeah i can't wait to see it too